cette maison de plain pied est en vente
depuis deux semaines à beloeil après une
dizaine de visites on attend toujours
une première offre d'achat avec le co
buhl c'était vraiment la folie furieuse
l'on sent que ça s'essouffle légèrement
mais ça retombe un peu comme à la
normale comme avant le coville et est
toujours un petit peu plus tranquille
les ventes de propriétés ont chuté de
18% dans le grand montréal en juillet
comparativement à l'an dernier mais les
prix continuent de grimper sur une
période d'un an c'est un bond de 10 %
pour les maisons unifamiliales de 9%
pour les copropriétés et de 15 % pour
les immeubles à logements le rythme
devrait toutefois ralentir selon ce
courtier hypothécaire
on pense qu'on a vraiment frappé le
plateau des prix l'on pense pas qu'on
pourrait présentement absorbé encore
d'autres hausses de primes pour les
propriétés gens sont simplement pas
capables de se payer les maisons la
hausse des taux d'intérêt et de
l'inflation semble avoir refroidi les
ardeurs de nombreux acheteurs le nombre
de propriétés sur le marché recommence à
grimper particulièrement dans les
couronnes nord et sud de montréal
ce qui n'avait pas été vu depuis
quelques années l'impact se fera sentir
les prix vont commencer à décroître et
c'est ce qu'on observe depuis quelques
mois on pense qu'on a atteint le sommet
un phénomène qu'on observe déjà dans la
grande région de toronto où les ventes
ont dégringolé de 40 7% en juillet il
brille moyen des propriétés a baissé de
près de 14% cours des six derniers mois
le marché qui était nettement favorable
aux vendeurs commencent à se
rééquilibrer il faut mettre au prix du
marché au war en deçà du prix du marché
pour non pas avoir des offres multiples
peut-être avoir déjà une offre et pas
nécessairement au prix que le vendeur
voudrait c'est le même portrait à
vancouver où les ventes ont reculé de
43% juillet et les prix de 5% au cours
des trois derniers mois on retourne tout
simplement
marché plus normale qui se tend à
s'équilibrer et ya pas lieu de paniquer
on est loin d'avoir perdu tout ce qu'on
a gagné 10 juin la pandémie avec des
prix qui fléchissent dans certains
marchés et une nouvelle hausse des taux
d'intérêt attendue cet automne de
nombreux acheteurs pourraient mettre
leur projet d'acheter une maison sur
pause le temps de voir comment la
situation évolue ici olivier bachand
radio canada montréal